um so i'm ashley fair a little bit about
me
i have been a recruiter for about seven
years
and i have been with hartwig's staffing
for just under about two years
um i have recruited on tech roles most
of my career but
i've really been 100 dedicated to tech
over the past year or two
where it's been my sole focus and i have
a passion and a love for the tech
industry
i love learning about new technologies
and listening to people talk about their
careers in the industry so
you know while i'm not maybe the most
technical person in the world i love
technology and
um i've been told that i'm tech adjacent
so we'll go with that
uh and then enough about me will kind of
dig into how to sell yourself in an
interview
um so most interviews will start with
an introduction or tell me about
yourself portion
and i'll kind of break this this whole
um
talk down a lot of it will be geared
towards
people who have experience in the
industry i have a section at the end
that i'll also
talk to junior developers who maybe only
have education or
you know projects on the side and less
experience
in the workforce um but what i'll do is
i'll break down
each um portion of this and explain how
it pertains to selling yourself and then
we'll dig into it and do some examples
and all of that
so going back um the introduction
portion or tell me about yourself
portion of an interview
selling yourself is that it's your first
interview i'm sorry your first
impression
um you know that they'll get of you this
is an overview
where you can tell them a little bit
about yourself and set the tone of the
entire interview
so on this i say keep it brief um
i no more than about a minute or so this
is not meant
to be a 10 to 15 um
don't tell your life story don't get too
personal
so i say keep it professional obviously
let your personality shine through
if you have relevant experience then
talk about how you
do the industry and if you're trying to
break into a
new industry explain how you became
interested in that industry
um and then it's okay to add some
personal interest just don't make this
entire thing
about your personal life so for example
if i were
hypothetically a software developer i
might say
my name is ashley farham i have seven
years of experience in software
development
my career started out in qa and i made a
natural progression
into development from there so
development was always a passion of mine
i knew that i would probably need to
gain a good foundation of knowledge
so i chose the qa route which allowed me
to build my skill set
and then i was promoted into development
after a year and a half of
working in qa um and
i've been on this road ever since and
then on a more personal note i love
kayaking i love hiking anything outdoors
and i'm really excited to be here today
so what i've done is not talked about my
entire work history and i didn't
take 10 minutes to tell you about you
know my entire life but i walked through
just a little bit about my career and my
transitions and then let a little bit of
my personality shine through in the end
and then next what you do um you know
walking through
explaining work history or your
experience and again these may not be in
order
so these are just talking points but
on explaining your work history and
experience and how that pertains to
selling yourself
is you have to be able to sell you to a
company
so um don't hesitate to really dig in
here and
get into depth you know prepare
um to explain that experience and i'll
really say this a lot but be very
specific
always talk in depth that's okay in an
interview you're there to sell yourself
you're there to talk about yourself
so you can break this down in a couple
of different ways
you can speak to projects that you've
been a part of um
and then talk about which projects you
were most proud of so
we're part of this really neat you know
greenfield project
or um what was something that you
enjoyed the most so maybe it wasn't a
huge project but it was something that
was just really fun to you
uh you can break down in those ways and
then um
you know what was your role in these
projects again
the more the more you can paint a
picture for them
the better another thing that i like to
have people do is
i'll say you know break down your purse
your position and percentages for me a
full stack developer does not mean
they do 50 50 development sometimes that
means 75
front end 25 back end or you know vice
versa
a software development manager they may
not do 100
managing a team um you know hands-on
leadership it could be where they're
doing half development and they're still
very hands-on in that
in that aspect but they also do uh
you know 50 leadership for a data person
they may spend 80 80 percent of their
time analyzing data and then
20 developing reports so
uh you can really break it down and
paint a picture that way
and then always make sure that you're
speaking to the technologies that you've
used
in each role but also in each project
so if somebody's title is a dot-net
developer
that doesn't mean that they've only used
net uh you know their entire career the
entire time they were in a particular
role
uh you know say you know for example i
would say
you know somebody had known anything
about typescript and then
the company decided to do a digital
transformation and wanted to move to
more
more of a modern tech stock they could
say you know so i jumped in and i
learned typescript
i created a prototype and we were able
to go to market with that
so make sure that you point those things
out because that might really stand out
to them that you have this additional
experience
and then also you know as you're walking
through work history explain your
journey
uh you know kind of explain how your
transition happened
or your transitions from role to role
happened
uh and then again i will say this a
million times during this presentation
i'll really talk about reading through a
job description
doing your research so make sure you've
read the job description
and you know is this more of a
maintenance position is it a greenfield
application
tailor your responses to the job
description so that you're speaking to
experience that pertains to the role um
you know make sure that you are talking
points that that pertain to that job
that you're interviewing for
that you don't want to narrow your focus
on something that isn't relevant to the
position
you might give off the idea that you
wouldn't enjoy key aspects of a specific
role
you might give off you know the
impression that you don't have the
experience for the position you're
interviewing for
and diana if you have anything to add
any at any point don't hesitate to
to interrupt me okay
okay uh so we'll move on to strengths
now on strengths um you know i would say
how this pertains to selling yourself
obviously the hiring manager
this is what i bring to the table here's
where i'm most confident
now with strengths i think technical
skills are just as important as soft
skills
um you know when you are talking with
a hiring manager and you
you can check every box on their job
description but if you don't have the
soft skills and you're not going to fit
in from
you know that perspective that can make
or break something for you or make or
break an interview for you
so highlight both um you know talk
through
technical skills so you know which
technologies are you most experienced
with
which are you most comfortable with and
be specific you can break down
maybe rank yourself you know from
you know on a scale from 1 to 10 or say
you know i'm advanced with x y and z
and i'm intermediate here but i would
still consider it to be a strength
uh you can also talk through you know
beyond that
are you a strong coder and you pick up
new languages easily
uh you know can you manage multiple
projects at once with ease
that's huge not everyone has that
capability are you a strong data person
and then from soft skills uh you know
talk about your leadership
experience are you a good communicator
do you welcome feedback
feedback is a great uh you know
something welcomes feedback is it's a
great quality to have
because it shows that you're wanting to
learn and progress in your career
and then you know just another point is
if someone adapts well
to different i.t environments that's
great um
now for example i might say you know
something along the lines of
i feel incredibly confident with react
and node and i would say those are my
primary languages i've also worked
closely with typescript over the past
year so i've become really familiar with
it
so reactant node i'm probably an eight
or nine out of ten i wouldn't say that
i'm perfect by any means
typescript you know with my year of
experience i would rank myself still a
six or a seven which i think is really
great
uh you know for for such a you know for
a newer language
um and then from a soft skills
perspective
i feel that i'm great at accepting
feedback and i actually welcome it i
utilize that feedback that i received to
help me grow professionally
and on another note you know in addition
to that is you can give
specific feedback or i'm sorry specific
examples so
um you know even when you're describing
your strengths regardless of
whether you're talking about technical
skills soft skills
you can give specific examples of both
of those
so when i say specific
talk about the business needs what did
the project accomplish
and you can do that as well you know
when you're talking through work
experience and work work history
what did that project accomplish you
know if you can
speak to how you have impacted business
needs
i think that that says a lot and i think
that would really impress a hiring
manager
and even more important than strengths i
feel like
um you know talking through weaknesses
on the weakness portion of an interview
i feel like this is a tough one for
people to answer so i put
a little extra love into this one um and
i broke it down into
do's and don'ts and how this pertains to
selling yourself
is you know it's it's not meant to be a
trick question
it shows the hiring manager your ability
to recognize a weakness
which is a good thing it's not bad we're
not perfect
and people who think they're perfect
that can also almost be more concerning
than someone who can recognize their
weaknesses
it gives you the opportunity to show
that you take initiative
to grow and learn from your weaknesses
if you answer this question the right
way
and this can really make or break an
interview so i say take this question
very seriously so on your don'ts
i say don't give a cliche answer now
if if these examples that i give if
they're truly your your
your greatest weakness then of course
share that
um but if they're not don't take the
easy way out and i gave these two
examples because if you google
you know example answers for greatest
weakness
these pop up a lot so well i'm not very
good at public speaking or
i have a really hard time walking away
from work and separating work and life
and so i spend a lot of time working
more than i should
or just walking away from my my computer
after hours
now like i said if that is your greatest
weakness definitely share that
but don't use it as a as an easy way out
and make sure you have read through the
job description and do not claim
a core part of the position so even if
you're not
incredibly experienced in a specific
part of the job description i'm not
saying to go ahead and confess that
there surely you have other weaknesses
you might be able to point out
um and on this one i put it under don'ts
it's kind of it can go both ways so be
cautious when pointing out a personality
trait
i would say that a lot of hiring
managers that i've talked with if
somebody points out a personality trait
say they don't deal with conflict or
they've had
issues with confrontation in the past
but they talk about how they've overcome
it well they may say
you know i'm too concerned this person's
confrontational and
some people think that personalities
can't be changed
now i'm not saying that's true but from
an interviewing you know just being in
this industry for so long
i've heard it this can shoot someone on
the foot of it
um but on the you know contrary
uh this can also weed out a company
that's not a good fit for you
you know so i someone gave me a good
example the other day of
you know i really like to be in the know
i want to know what's going on i want to
be hands on
i don't like being in the dark and
for that personally important to get
into a role that fit that
personality trait for her so even if she
didn't get the position because of
you know expressing that well it weeded
out a role that was probably not going
to be a good fit for her
after all so again i put this here but
it's
it's really just be cautious and really
think through what you're saying
and how you present that
another thing don't claim to have no
weaknesses i
interview people all the time and i will
ask you know what are your strengths
what are you good at and
you know what's something you feel like
you can improve in and
a lot of times it's not even people
claiming that they don't have them
but it could just be oh i can't think of
anything make sure that you think about
this ahead of time you don't want to
give the answer i don't have a weakness
um and the reason being is that
if you claim not to have a weakness a
hiring manager is going to think that
you might think that you're perfect
or they may think you're not coachable
um it's okay to be humble and have a
weakness
so next um
oh i was going to jump in really quick
yeah please so um
going back just a tiny bit on the the
strengths
don't be afraid to pitch yourself and to
talk talk yourself up because you need
to be your greatest advocate
and i know that a lot of us have a
really hard time with that i
for a long time had a really hard time
with that um
but go talk to people go talk to people
who you know have a positive impression
of you
um ask what they think your best assets
are and have conversations
and as you're meeting strangers go out
and network and
introduce yourself and don't be afraid
to
to interview and talk about what you're
good at or things like that just for
some practice it makes it easier when
you go into the interviews
and i would say yes absolutely be
cautious on your personality traits
but don't be afraid to be yourself when
i first got
started because i was self-taught and i
went into interviews
um i had several times where i was told
that i wasn't the right culture fit for
one reason or another
um and at the time i was really upset
because i just wanted a job
but in hindsight i realized that by
being patient
um and especially since i didn't
need to have a job at that moment in
time it certainly would make our lives a
lot easier
since i didn't have to have one at that
exact moment in time that it was kind of
a blessing because then
in hindsight i realized that i would
have been miserable working at these
places
and so if they can't accept me for who i
am
um and they can't accept my personality
and things like that then
i'm gonna be miserable there and i want
somebody who
who will accept me for who i am and i by
by staying true to myself i've ended up
with a job that i absolutely love to
death yes
i thoroughly agree with that i think it
is really important to
to be yourself and i think people kind
of
stray away from that and are just afraid
to be themselves in an interview because
you do you just want the position so
badly or maybe you really need
one but that's such a good point that
you know don't be afraid to be yourself
you you do want to find a good long-term
fit and if you go into something you
know faking it and not
letting them get a true picture of who
you are
you'll be miserable or the role won't
last very long
so i i completely agree with that and
i also agree on you know selling
yourself
it is just it's really uncomfortable to
talk about yourself
it's not fun um you know i think a lot
of people struggle with that but i agree
that this is your chance that's what the
interview is about it's about you
and selling yourself and talking about
yourself
so i completely agree
um okay so
on that try not to give a previous
weakness that's no longer a weakness
uh and and what i mean by that is is you
know don't say
i would say you know a year ago my
greatest weakness was javascript but
i've used it in several projects over
the past year so it's really no longer a
weakness i'm actually
doing really well with javascript now um
well then it's not a weakness
so we'll go over to the do's and then
i'll give
an example but on dues
so do point out a true weakness that's
okay
like i mentioned previously now let's
make sure we're reading through the job
description and we're not
pointing out a weakness that is a key
factor to this position
but surely you have a few weaknesses and
um you know it's it's okay to point that
out
so it's all about how you present it now
are there languages or other
technologies that you wish you had more
experience with
um or something that you gained
experience with
in in school or previous position and
you just haven't used it in a while
now a good way to overcome that is just
to explain i have a great foundation of
knowledge
and you know i i could pick it up
quickly i just need a refresher or
some hands-on experience you know i just
need a little bit of time and i'd be up
to par again but it's not something that
i'd be learning from scratch
so i'd say that's a good example but
when you're talking about weaknesses
always explain how you're working to
improve it um and
i even say describe it you know like an
area of opportunity rather than a
weakness so an
area of improvement something that
you i just don't have a lot of
experience with now but but i'm working
on it or i'm getting better
and i also say always have more than one
example
so typically when this is asked in an
interview it's usually what is your
greatest weakness or you know
your biggest weakness or something along
those lines but
um what if a hiring manager you know
from time to time they may say well what
else
maybe they didn't like your first answer
or maybe they just want to know another
and you don't want to have to come up
with this on the spot
it would be tough to come up with on the
spot so you may just have a few examples
prepared
and oh go ahead yeah i was going to stay
on this one
um so when i applied for my current job
with ou
i went in having two things that i kind
of spoke on
one was um my anxiety
that i tend to um
overthink things and make things
slightly more difficult
than they sometimes need to be um so
i try to ask them is how what is your
policy or how do you feel about
having someone one of your employees
come and talk to you when they start
doing that to kind of use you as a
sounding board
to kind of clear their mind and get
their mind they'll get their thinking
straight
um and then also i had mentioned that
i'm not bad at marketing but i
definitely could do better and i
struggle i feel like i struggle with it
um so is there someone there that can
help with that
is that something that i can get
assistance with while i work on
improving those and i can learn from
them and things like that
so i try to ask if there's for what my
weaknesses are is there some type of
support or what could you do to
potentially help me overcome those
again i love that because that really
it is just some as important for a role
to be a good fit for you
as it is for the for you to fit their
role
um so i love that you are able to you
know put that out there and be kind of
vulnerable in an interview
interview and ask i think that's great
to see if it aligns with
you as a person yeah and if they're not
going to accept you as that person then
it's not the right fit for you
right i i definitely agree there
i gave a an example here so more of a
technical example
is what i gave but so um
say you know you're applying to a manual
testing role
i would say something tangibly related
to the job so you could say
this is an automation but i'm intrigued
by automation
so i've been reading up on some sql or
you know specific automation tools and
so it's
definitely something i'm not opposed to
learning my strength is just obviously
in
manual but i would say as a weakness
probably automation
and then that way you know it's not
something that
pertains very specifically to the role
that you're interviewing for
but it's a true weakness and something
that you could improve upon
you also didn't say i don't want to do
it i'm not interested
and if you weren't if it's not something
you're interested in you could share
that as well but
this is just kind of a good well-rounded
way to maybe explain
a weakness and our next
uh topic will be uh so why would you
be a fit for the role or why would you
be a fit for this company
and how this pertains to selling
yourself again
this is another opportunity to show what
you bring to the table
so i i think this is probably the
biggest opportunity to sell yourself
really because you're literally saying
this is why i fit your
job this is why i fit your company
so i say that again i will say this a
thousand times
make sure you have done your research
and then use a formula
i use this formula or i tell people that
they can use this formula so i say
culture plus skill set plus how it fits
you
and i'll explain what each of those mean
and then i will
also give an example kind of using all
of those um
but so with culture you know
check out the company culture online and
their core values
do your research online look at their
website
um look at their linkedin profile look
at employees linkedin profiles
what are people posting you can get a
lot of information about a company's
culture
you can obviously get their core values
typically from their website
and then figure out you know does this
company or do their goals
and their values align with yours and if
so explain how they align
and explain what you can bring to the
table from a company culture perspective
uh and then make sure you've read your
job description thoroughly
and you can talk through what you bring
to the table from a skill set
perspective you know have you been in a
specific industry for
you know a certain amount of time and so
you meet their years of experience and
um you know you can talk through again
the technologies and
and you know your strengths there and
that experience
and then when i say you know how it fits
you
does the does the role align with you
know why you're looking for a position
and then how so maybe you were laid off
and this utilizes your current skill set
and matches what you enjoy doing to the
team
then it's perfect uh you know or maybe
you're looking for the next step in your
career and you're looking for a step
up or you could have recently graduated
or just obtained a degree
overall or you may have working
experience and obtained a degree in
something new you know all of those
things are great things to point out how
it fits you as well
i think talking through how the company
fits you
it it really gives a hiring manager kind
of a
sense of ease you know that you will
stick around long term
and for an example you know i would say
like
at heartwood staffing so my company for
example
one of our core values is grit and if i
were to apply to
you know my job today and interview for
it something i might say is
um you know i researched the company and
i saw that grit is one of your core
values
and something that i pride myself on is
the fact that
i have had to overcome adversity in my
life and
this has really instilled grit into me
as a person
so i think we align well there from that
perspective
when i get knocked down which tends to
happen a lot in this industry
you know i can get back up and i'm
motivated more motivated than ever
probably
and you know when i'm talking from a
skill set perspective i feel like i'm a
fit because you know i come with seven
years of experience in recruiting
i've recruited on everything under the
sun but tech is where my passions lie
and so i'm passionate about what you all
are doing
and i'm looking for that next step in my
career and this opportunity
offers just that so you know
what i did there i talked about how i
relate
to their culture and their core values
and how they relate to me and match me
and then i explained how my skill set
fits um but then i also explained again
you know um it aligns with my reason for
looking for something new
so i'm going to stick around i'm going
to be loyal to you
with my experience with applying at the
ou innovation hub
i didn't feel like i necessarily had
project lead or project management
experience i
all of my experience had been a lot of
in the volunteer realm um but when this
came up
everybody kept saying diana this is a
great fit that's great that you have to
go apply for this so i took them at
their word i trusted them on it
um and i pointed out that
when i see a need for something or i see
something that needs to be
or that i see as a gap i try to figure
out what can we do
to try to fix it or to help fill that
gap
and i'm always looking for trying new
things
trying to build new things trying to
innovate things
um creating new programming for
teclahoma or oklahoma women technology
things like that um and that is what the
ihub is all about so the position i
ended up taking was for a role that they
had an idea of what they wanted
but it was up to me to go in and create
it and so by me saying that i enjoy
creating things and trying new things
and if
something doesn't work out trying
something else and not giving up and
having that grit to do that
um it ended up being an absolute perfect
fit
and that is such a good point also you
know
don't only apply to jobs that you check
every single box on their job
description
um you know when i branched into
recruiting i had
no recruiting experience and i applied
to the job because i was
really interested in it and you know my
my interests and my passions and i had
leadership experience and i had done
some interviewing
as a manager in the past and so just
because you don't have that
exact experience you can still point out
what you bring to the table from a skill
set perspective
even if it doesn't match a job
description to the t so
i'm really glad you brought that up
because i don't i probably don't hone in
on that a lot during this talk
really good point
um okay so next
asking questions and on this one i
you know i i how i'm relating this to
selling yourself
is that this is how you're expressing
your interest in the company
so for example you know almost imagine
if you went on a first date
and this person's asking all these
questions about you and getting to know
you and you're having all this fun you
know talking about yourself
but then what if you had no questions
for them you know you kind of end it you
didn't ask them one thing about
themselves
so you can almost think of it like that
and they may think
well do they like me um so again this is
not dating but
it could be relative um and
so i would say this this is showing
interest um and you come with several
questions prepared
what happens all of the time in an
interview you know you're getting a lot
of them from
information during an interview you're
talking through a lot of different
points
so it's very likely a lot of your
questions will get answered
um during your interview so i always
say have backup questions prepared
um have lots of questions prepared
because
half of them will be answered during the
interview uh and then i gave a few
examples of questions that you can ask
here
now on this i would say
have way more than four questions
prepared but these are just some good
questions and kind of to get you
thinking on
you know in this direction so you can
ask some pretty standard basic questions
as well but i'll kind of give you my
reasoning behind
these these specifically so
one with you know how long have you been
with the company um you can ask
your interviewers you know how long have
you been with this company
what are some things that you really
like about the company or what are some
things that you really like about your
position if you're interviewing for
something similar you know to to the
role that they hold
you can ask um you know uh
same thing about your your position the
company what are some things that you
feel like
could improve what are some some kind of
pain points
within the company or within your
position um
you can also ask why the rules are open
so that's
something that's really interesting to
know because if it's because of growth
that's really neat you know it sounds
like the company's growing um if
somebody's left
well people leave for all sorts of
reasons but maybe somebody left because
it wasn't a good fit for them
well if they're willing and open they
may share with you why that person left
and well you it could go one of two ways
one or
one of two ways there you know you could
determine that
wow they left and you know the reason
that they left really kind of matches
my personality so i'm hope i don't know
if this would be a good fit for me
but at the same time it could just be oh
wow you know i really
i match what they were lacking or what
they didn't enjoy about this role i
really enjoy
uh so you can determine you know from
there that can really help you
see if it's a good fit
another question so immediate challenges
you see for someone coming into the role
you know you talk about the position
uh you know being open because of growth
so they may say well you know we're
looking to add to the team and right now
we're
kind of underwater or it's a little
chaotic so when somebody joins the team
it's going to be really busy and it's
going to look a little crazy
but now that we'll have you know an
extra set of hands that will
slowly balance itself out and hopefully
we'll kind of get back to normal
and um you know have more of a balance
but um walking into it yes you may walk
into some
oh chaos ahead uh so
one of the things i was thinking about
here the way that i usually approach
this
is i go in with at least a list of 20
questions
because i found that absolutely most of
the time
almost all of my questions will be
answered um so if i go in with the list
of questions in front of me
if i wind up not having any at least
they can see that i came in prepared
and that maybe they feel good about how
the interview went if they answered all
of my questions
um yeah and if i feel like i need to ask
something um i try to think back on
previous problems that i've had
at with previous jobs and
i bring those up as like a situational
if this were to happen
how would this be handled or something
like that to
to kind of gauge how things might go
yeah no i love that and i'm glad you
kind of put a number to it as well
because when i say a lot 20 is a great
number
um because you're like you say you can
come in with 20 questions and there is a
chance that all 20 may be answered
but it can happen uh you know like i
said you just you
get a lot of information uh during an
interview and you're talking through so
many different points
so and another great point one it shows
initiative and it shows you i wrote a
list of 20 questions i truly did have
questions even if they did all end up
getting
answered um and don't hesitate to bring
in
you know a nice notebook with you with
questions
and you know now don't walk in and read
your resume verbatim or anything like
that
but it's okay to have some talking
points jotted down
um do not sit there and read but
just something you know if you have like
she said you know having a list of
questions prepared is great
um i definitely i think that's great and
also i don't take me too literally
literally when i say bring a notebook
and have talking points don't
you know go in and have your
introduction written out you know i want
to reiterate don't sit there and read
from a piece of paper
um it will not go well
um okay so the the final portion on
asking questions uh you know do you have
any
concerns regarding my background for
this role
i love this question and it's it's a
vulnerable
question to ask and it's it might be a
hard question to ask for some people and
i
you know i completely understand that
but
if you ask that it gives you a chance to
overcome any concerns that they have
right then and there if they're open and
honest with you um
then you can address a concern before
you walk away rather than
if you don't ask this and you walk away
then we'll say oh we're passing because
of you know x y or z
when you might have been able to address
that right then and there
absolutely uh i do i
interview and i do have employees who
work for me
absolutely there's been times where it's
been really close
between a couple of people and
there might be one tiny thing on the
resume that we're like
uh that's maybe not a red flag but it
might be a yellow flag so
let's go with this other person so i
love love love that question
yeah i agree you know that's another
good point i'll give an example that's
different but
you know to what you're saying it's you
if you're comparing apples to apples and
you have two
really good candidates being able to
address something like that might be
the the deal breaker so um
now an example i have too on a just kind
of a different note
is um you know i had a candidate
who most of his recent experience was in
project management and he was applying
to uh
or interviewing for a project management
position
but he had several years of development
experience prior to that
a lot more development experience
than he did project and
um he was very focused or the interview
just became really focused on his
development experience so
the interviewers started digging into
that more and he talked about it more
and it just got off track
and he did not get to talk about his
project management experience nearly as
much as he
should have and wanted to um and the
the hiring managers ended up passing
because
the interview ended up just being so
geared towards project i'm sorry towards
development and
he walked away regretting not having
been able to speak to that experience
more
and so you know i almost wonder had he
interviewed or ended the interview and
asked
do you have any concerns regarding my
background for this role you know they
might have said
you know our only concern is yes you do
have project management experience but
it seems like
you're a little more passionate about
dev or you know
it seems like your your experience is
just heavier on the development side
and we we need somebody who's really you
know honed in and
senior uh senior level with project
management experience
and who knows he might have been able to
really dig into that
he could have said do you mind if i you
know kind of dig into my project
management experience a little more i
feel like we
we got off track and i did i talked a
lot about my development experience so i
can see why you would think
that's where my passions lie or you know
that's where my strengths are
anything else to add there um we do have
one comment
um in slack that it seems to see
deceitful to present yourself as meeting
qualifications for a position when you
don't
it also really bothers me as a developer
when companies don't know the
meaning of the word requirements which i
get
um but after talking to some recruiters
and realizing that that requirement
is really more suggested than absolute
and that you want to go into your next
job
looking for an opportunity to grow into
the position
versus you're going to be bored if you
go into it and you meet all the
qualifications 100
right no i understand that completely as
well i i
i agree in a lot of ways but i'll say
i'll say also hiring managers when
they're writing a job description
their dream perfect candidate
you know they most times a hiring
manager knows someone won't check
every single box on the job description
but it's good to read through it and you
can you know at least go into it with a
good foundation of knowledge
and you can admit if you don't have
experience in certain areas you know i
definitely don't want anybody
to go in and try to deceive um
a company uh you know that or a hiring
manager you know for a role that you're
interviewing for
it's okay to not check every box but
obviously you do want to make sure that
you're checking at least some of those
core boxes
exactly that's exactly what i was just
thinking was as long as you meet the
core requirements
and you can do the basic necessities of
the job you're good
and if there's areas that you can grow
into and learn almost all of us who do
hiring
understand that we're going to need to
coach in a couple of areas and help you
learn in a couple of areas
and we generally budget time and
finances for that
yeah and you can go in and say you know
that that's where the the portion of
selling yourself and
showing that you know you can learn
things on the fly you know talk about
you know while i don't you know i meet
your your core requirements i may not
meet a few of these additional
you know kind of preferences and you
know but here's an example of what i did
in the past and how i learned something
really quickly and on the fly
um you know or that i i didn't have any
experience in
this field when i when i came in and i
learned it
and you know i did a great job within a
year i was promoted you know talk about
those things
ashley what are your thoughts on maybe
potentially using those periods of
growth as
potential weaknesses during the
interview and that that's what you want
to grow into
oh absolutely i think that's a great way
to
to kind of target that answer or you
know kind of gear the answer in that
direction i think that's fantastic
any other questions so far um
not that i see okay so we'll move on to
our closing statement on closing
statement
um you know i this this portion of
selling yourself this is
wrapping everything up it's just as
important as your introduction your
introduction is
that first impression this is your last
impression your final words so you want
to make it count
um you know have a closing statement
prepared
you know you get to sum up why you're a
good fit for the role how you're a good
fit for the role
and when i say have it prepared you know
have a general statement prepared
but pay attention during your interview
and
be specific and point out things that
they talked about during the interview
and then you can even wrap it up with
another question so i know we have the
the questions portion and you can ask
any of these questions there
or here but you know some of these might
be a good way to just kind of end
your uh interview with you know what are
next steps or
when should i expect to hear back uh
when are you looking to make a decision
and then another one you know making
sure to ask uh you know if i have any
questions who would be the best person
to reach out to
and i'll kind of dig into why you know
that's important in a second but
you know for example a closing statement
for me personally i could say is
something like you know again i just
like to thank everyone for their time
i loved how you described your team
dynamic and how each person
brings their own piece of the puzzle and
and strength to the table
you know as i mentioned previously i
think that i bring that grit to the
table
you know that you speak of in your core
values and i have the years of
experience and the technical knowledge
you're looking for
and i'd be honored to be a part of your
team so can you tell me what next steps
would look like for me
or you know you could ask like i said
you know if i have any additional
questions after this
who would be the best person to reach
out to um
and for a couple of reasons to reach out
to truly if you have questions
then you'd like to know who to reach out
to but also kind of takes me into
my next slide on um thank you notes so
in your thank you note 2 to that person
or to your recruiter
but you know people just don't send
thank you notes anymore
and i'm not saying that these are
necessary or that you have to do it
no most hiring managers don't
necessarily expect it
but if you're interviewing against
multiple people
this this is one definite way to stand
out because it's
there's a strong likelihood that the
other people they interviewed
probably are not sending a thank you
note um
do you like getting thank you notes we
love it
okay then it shows us that you care
about the job
and that's that's absolutely at least
where i work is going to give you an
edge
so there's a better chance of you
getting hired if you send a thank you
note because we
we care more about your passion and your
your excitement for the position than we
do checking all the boxes
yeah and i've even seen so i'll talk
through with lincoln now but i've even
seen people
interview and then just like send the
people that they talk to on the
uh or they talk to you during their
interview they'll get on linkedin and
find them and just say hey it was
awesome talking to you
like just something engaging is is
really nice but
this is is a like you know diana said
this is a really good way to show
i am interested and here's why and so
you know
when you start your interview you should
have that nice notebook
um drop down the names of the people
that are interviewing you
and then you can include that and
address them specifically
in the thank you note thank them for
their time and then
address again what you bring to the
table maybe put a couple of bullet
points in there
you know just just wanted to remind you
you know i bring x y and z to the table
um you know and i would just really be
interested in joining the company and
you know kind of circle back around on
why you're interested in the company or
the role
um so i won't talk about thank you notes
a ton it's not
a super sell yourself thing but i think
it i mean i guess it really is it's it's
definitely something that people have
gotten away from it is and you can do
it either in an email or what i usually
do
is i've got the old fashioned
hallmark blank thank you cards
i write out the address on the front of
the envelope i have it stamped i have
the thank you note written out i have
everything on there but the names
and i just fill out the names and then i
look for i literally look for a mailbox
on my way out of the building and drop
it in the mailbox as i'm leaving the
building oh wow
that way i don't forget it that's great
no that's great i
i definitely i like that you point out
there are multiple ways to
to deliver that as well yeah but we but
i have we love getting emails just the
same so it really doesn't matter which
way you do it but
the sooner you do it the better yes that
is another thing
some of the you may have you may be too
late sometimes
absolutely because sometimes there's
times we because by law we have
with us being an uh a government
education facility we have to
interview a minimum of three people for
every position
um and sometimes if you're the first
person to interview
then it might be a month or two before
we get
we find two other candidates to
interview but if you're the last one to
interview there's a good chance we
already know who we're going to ask we
need to fill that position quickly
and we're going to act almost
immediately so always assume that you're
that third
you're that last interview and like make
a decision as soon as you walk out that
door because oftentimes we do
yeah i like that always assume that
you're the final interview
okay so this is just my section on i
just have a couple of slides for i i say
junior developers
um because i feel like junior developers
are you know
that they make our world go around and
and
they have a hard time breaking into the
industry sometimes so
a lot of that you know a lot of what i
said can definitely still relate to you
but
um yeah here's just some some special
love
um you know again come armed with
knowledge i said i would say this a
million times and i think i say it again
in a minute but
do your research uh you know make sure
you've researched the company make sure
you've researched
the position um you're really going to
have to sell yourself
and so when you don't have actual
working experience
talk about the actual experience that
you do have it doesn't have to be in the
workplace but
maybe you took some classes you have a
specific degree
um you know what were you know were you
a part of any particular projects or did
you do a boot camp
or multiple boot camps you know have you
been doing tutorials lately
talk about what you've done and then
i'll continue this on the next page but
talk about projects outside of your
education too so
if you are a junior developer and you
don't have a github
i highly highly suggest getting one um
you know i i think that
nine times out of ten um if i have a
hiring manager who is open to a junior
developer
they are going to say send me their
github and
they hiring managers definitely look at
that so
be prepared to discuss your github repo
in an interview
keep your repos updated and somebody who
has an
active account and frequent commits is
going to stand out just because you have
a github
if you don't use it it it doesn't help
you
um and then you know for maybe our
design people or uiuxers or you know
kind of that geared more towards that if
you have a portfolio or not if
make sure you have a portfolio you know
you have to show your work
firing managers want to see people's
work in general but especially if you're
a junior developer
if you can show something that's that's
going to help that's going to help you
stand out
um and just for you know
an example on the the project piece i
i would say so i talked to somebody just
the other day
and he loves video games and so i just
said you know talk me through some
projects that you've done
it doesn't have to be in work but just
talk me through have you done anything
for fun or
and he gave an example he loves video
games he hates picking out which game to
play
um so he actually created this
application where he can go in
and click a button and it goes through
his entire video game library
picks a game and opens it up and then it
starts so he has to put
zero thought into his his his gaming
session
um and that's just really neat so you
know i talked through with him what what
what did you use you know
which languages did you use to do that
or you know what technologies did you
use
um that just because you didn't do it at
work it he did it and it works and it's
actually a really neat project if you
ask me
uh and then something else i just wanted
to touch on is that you're not going to
know
every answer to their questions you know
and that's okay
they're you know the goal is they're
they're trying to figure out
what what level of knowledge you do have
and so if you don't know the answer to a
question
not a problem don't don't fake it don't
make something up
admit it and speak to how you'd find the
answers so um you know
how would you learn say you don't know
it well what would you do to learn it
you know i would you know i actually i
wouldn't have any problem going home
tonight
and you know signing up for a boot camp
or hopping on some tutorials and just
you know i might just brush up on that
and play with it just to to do that
talk about you can always talk about
previous work history even if it's not
technical
so if you learned something quickly
maybe you were given a task and you
didn't really know
you didn't have that skill set did you
learn something quick did you learn
something on the on the job
um show that you you're willing and
capable of doing that even if it's not
exactly a technical example
so just a little tidbit for junior
developers and
anyone who wants to reach out to me
obviously is welcome to but you know
junior developers i am so
i'm more than happy to talk through
you know anything i can with you to give
you advice you know whatever that looks
like
don't hesitate to reach out to me and
i'll get my contact info here in just a
minute i have a
i think one more slide and then i'll
give you my contact info
so just to conclude uh everything
research do your research that is going
to be
so important for you um you know going
into an interview just
stacked with knowledge the more
information you have the better you're
going to perform
if you're sitting there trying to dig
into your brain and make things up and
it just you're not going to perform well
in an interview so
research come in ready to go read your
job descriptions look at your websites
whatever you need to do linkedin is a
great resource and then practice and
prepare so
for your friends and just go through
even just standard interview questions
you know a lot of interviews you'll get
some standard interview questions so
you know whatever that looks like for
you um you know walk through those and
practice with your friends
and you know be confident so this goes
all the way back to you know earlier
when diana said
don't be afraid to brag about yourself
people don't like doing it
but that's your job in an interview
that's your
sole focus is to sit there and brag
about yourself and to talk about your
experience
and to talk about your accomplishments
um you know you you cannot
you can't not talk about yourself and
brag about yourself and
do very well in an interview so have
some confidence
be proud of yourself be proud of your
accomplishments however
big or small you feel like they are you
know if you're sitting
in that scene in front of a hiring
manager you're in a good spot
so um anyways so that's all i have for
selling yourself one more thing on the
bragging about yourself
um one way that i kind of helped
overcome that a little bit
is instead of thinking about
i'm good at this or i'm good at that i
talk about how proud or excited i was
when i accomplished certain things
and that's one way that you can kind of
redirect that a little bit and still
highlight what you've done
um and talk yourself up without feeling
like
you're bragging about yourself i love
that verbage
you know something that i'm really that
i was really proud of or you can say you
know i did
x y and z and i was really proud of that
i i really like that it does
it does sound um almost better than i'm
really good at this and i'm really good
at that
so i love that
i'll put my contact information up you
can search my name and linkedin
email me that's my direct line if you'd
like to call me
uh don't hesitate to reach out if i can
you know further elaborate on anything
that we talked about today if you need
help with
anything interview-esque um you know i'm
i'm happy to be a resource for
for anyone saying if you have any
questions about tecla home or anything
i'm at diana or at diana barnes
either on taclomaslack or any social
media
so feel free to reach out to me if you
have any questions about anything
okay thank you ashley so much for being
here today we really appreciate this was
a great talk
yeah thank you for having me i loved it